so ilhan Omar who is a Somali immigrant
first generation immigrant into the
United States uh who has become powerful
and influential here in this country and
a congresswoman uh and I believe her to
be actually an enemy of the United
States of America and the people of
Minnesota I suppose will have to decide
if they want to reelect or her not uh
here she is finally chiming in on what's
going on in Gaza reminder Gaza doesn't
have shelters or an Iron Dome and to
please pray for them may peace Prevail
in the region and move us towards a
moral Awakening to care about human
suffering we are seeing Palestinians are
human beings who have been besieged and
are deserving of protection from the
International Community well
Palestinians are besieged she's right by
Hamas there's not one Israeli that lives
in Gaza they completely moved every
Israeli out there were about 8,000 Jews
living there Hitler would love the place
there's not one Jew right like that's
what Hitler wanted right Jud and Ry
there's none there they left they said
we want nothing to do with you they left
green houses they left infrastructure
Hamas took over they killed their
opposition and for all of these years
all of the billions and billions of
dollars that Hamas got and what did they
build they clearly built an an
incredibly effective Guerilla Army
instead of building say bomb shelters or
an Iron Dome or anything else she's just
a communist I don't know how to say it
any other way sorry if you're watching
with the kids what you know what am I
going to do I have to tell you what I
think
[Music]